les salariés d'antarctique usine de
production de boissons non alcoolisées
pour les magasins intermarché sont en
grève depuis ce matin 5 heures elle se
sentant lésé choix direct si au niveau
des augmentations est inquiet et de la
potentielle restructuration de
l'entreprise plusieurs employés ont
décidé de stopper leur activité
ainsi ni le comité social économique ni
les syndicats n'ont été consultés elle
est salariée tienta rappeler à qui les
soutiennent nous là on a lancé ce
mouvement que entre les salariés
c'est au contraire c'est pour soutenir
justement l'action qui a été fait par
les syndicats on a un c est ce qui aussi
qui nous représente ont fait leur
travail dans le temps les moyens qu'ils
avaient dans le temps qu'ils avaient ils
ont fait tout ce qu'ils pouvaient là ils
sont arrivés à un moment
ils sont au pied du mur et nous on
on a décidé de pour les soutenir et pour
essayer de leur redonner des billes pour
que tu puisse continuer à négocier de
sortir de nous-mêmes